[Music]
[Applause]
2012 was a life-changing year for me in
May I got pregnant and then I found out
I was having the high-risk pregnancy
requiring me to be on bed rest for 16
hours a day
on my side so to kill time and entertain
myself
I decided to go on amazon.com and buy
all the highly rated parenting books the
charge reading them the more I read the
more confident I got about my ability to
take on this new challenge I knew it was
going to be hard but in typical V DITA
fashion I had figured out everything
that could potentially go wrong and then
come up with mitigation strategies to
address those challenges so here I was
ready to take this on and then Kim Zara
a very happy and healthy baby four and a
half pounds seventeen and a half inches
long with a vocal capacity of 88
decibels those first few moments were so
precious the first few years
not so much I went back to taking a
full-time job which was very stressful
my husband Sandeep was trying to start a
new business so he also was working
really long hours we hired a full-time
nanny to take care of Zara Zara was
spending a lot of time with the nanny so
not surprisingly Zara got really
attached to the nanny and this really
bothered me but then I remembered in one
of the books that I had read Sheryl
Sandberg in her book lean in talked
about being in the exact same
predicament that I was in so I was like
hey Cheryl went through this you're
going through this it's really no big
deal just don't sweat it
but that advice was really hard for me
to hold on to
the evenings got progressively harder
and the weekends were even worse much of
what I had read in those books was just
not working for me on a daily basis and
it didn't take me long to figure out
there was somebody else in the house who
had it all figured out sumeet knew
exactly what to say how to say it what
to do when to do it how to do it he
essentially had the motherly instinct
that was supposed to be mine
it was my precious gift for carrying our
child for nine months and for the first
time in my life I was jealous of Sandeep
how could it be that I was so successful
at work getting stellar performance
reviews and at home I couldn't even put
Legos together it really frustrated me
to see that and I carried this
frustration into work every day so I
distinctly remember that day in June
2015 I was in I was basically running
from meeting to meeting trying to cope
with everything that was being thrown at
me that day and it was Dora's wellness
appointment at 2:00 p.m. that day and I
didn't want to be late but despite my
best intentions I was late so I showed
up the appointment went really well
Xaro was thriving as a toddler and then
when the appointment was over Sandeep
took Zara back to the car while I waited
there in the office in this really tiny
space probably ten feet by five feet
waiting for my pediatrician to print her
growth charts so here I was standing
there very lost in my thoughts and just
staring at the ground and she looked at
me and she said
so how's it going I have no idea what it
was about those words but the next thing
I knew I was crying and this was no
gentle cry this was really loud and ugly
with lots of Kleenex smudged eyeliner of
the mass and I don't know what it was it
was there was nothing special about what
she said but it was as if she knew
exactly what was going on in my mind she
probably seen this before but for me it
was a first and I was standing there
feeling really lost and completely
defeated by motherhood it took me
several days to process what had
occurred and I think I finally figured
it out from the day I got pregnant and
possibly even before I conceived I had
this image of this perfect mom this mom
who's on time for all her appointments
her house looks really clean the sink is
not piled with dirty dishes the laundry
is completely taken care of
tucked away in drawers she organizes
playdates for her daughter she reads to
her daughter probably in more than two
languages and she's on top of it and I
was miles away from achieving any of
this on a consistent basis and this
really made bothered me it made me
frustrated and angry which made me
Restless in my own skin and my daughter
could feel that which is why she was
running away from me making me feel
worse and this cycle just continued so I
have spent a lot of time thinking about
this and many whiteboard sessions later
I think I finally cracked the code on
this internal dichotomy of a personality
trait that it's so engrained in me so on
one hand this continuous strive for
perfection
please to stress anxiety it lowers my
confidence levels
it makes me unsure of myself and in many
ways it really increases my desire to be
accepted in this world it's what made
those first few years with Zara really
hard but on the other hand it's de
strive for perfection that results in
beautiful products whether that is at
work or at home in the kitchen you can
ask my husband about every meal that I
cook it is done in the absolute hard way
there are no shortcuts but I think what
it results in is a perfect meal or if
he's perfect from my standards and it
makes me happy so and I really cannot
forget that it is that perfection that
got me to the GSB
this dichotomy is really tense but this
tension is beautiful it is this even
today
what does not exist today though is this
constant agony to try to fight it
because what I've realized is that at my
core I'm a perfectionist
I just cannot change that what I can
change is how and when I apply it to my
life
and because essentially what I don't do
anymore is try to apply this
perfectionism to relationships because
relationships are not like recipes two
tablespoons of love and three teaspoons
of compassion is not equal a happy baby
letting my guard down to really be
myself and who I am is what makes me the
mom I want to be and it is this
imperfect mom that Zahra loves thank you
[Applause]
[Music]